communiqué commun les discussions
devaient initialement se terminer ce
dimanche le havre et charleville
mézières commence demain un dépistage
massif les deux premières villes
françaises a lancé à l'opération
al'approche des fêtes de fin d'année
l'inquiétude est grande face au coc u19
l'allemagne d'ici d'un site sera confiné
partiellement dès mercredi commerce non
essentiels écoles fermeront à triste
record du côté vitaly avait plus de 64
mille morts le pays devient le plus
endeuillé d'europe
au roi noyés d'eau ne parvient pas à
mobiliser au venezuela
l'opposant avait convoqué une
consultation populaire symbolique contre
nicolás maduro derniers jours ce
dimanche une semaine après la victoire
aux législatives du parti du président
élu et un bilan mitigé
nous le verrons
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france les discussions
vont donc se poursuivre entre londres et
bruxelles pour éviter en odile sur le
break site résultats de l'entretien
téléphonique à la mi journée entre le
premier ministre britannique et la
présidente de la commission européenne
une énième prolongation des négociations
alors qu'elle devait initialement
prendre fin à ce dimanche est le temps
presse car le 31 décembre avec ou sans
accord commercial le royaume uni
quittera l'union européenne pierre
pissavy yvernault hier encore le royaume
uni et l'union européenne semblait bien
pessimiste quant à une issue positive
des négociations long d'avocats une
offre inacceptable de l'union européenne
quand bruxelles estimé que les chances
d'aboutir à un accord devenait de plus
en plus minces si les deux parties se
sont donné jusqu'à ce soir pour enfin
trouver un accord est la présidence de
la commission européenne confirme à la
mi-journée la poursuite des négociations
j'ai eu un appel téléphonique
constructif et utile avec le premier
ministre boris johnson
nous avons discuté des principaux sujets
non résolus nos équipes de négociation
travaillé jour et nuit ces derniers
jours et malgré l'épuisement
après presque un an de négociations et
malgré le fait que les délais étaient et
maintes fois manqué nous pensons tous
deux qu'il est responsable
à ce stade ci de faire un effort
supplémentaire nous avons donc chargé
nos négociateurs de poursuivre les
pourparlers et de voir si un accord peut
être conclu
même à ce stade tardif les négociations
se poursuivent ici à bruxelles des sluts
in prague bruxelles et londres vont donc
tenter un effort supplémentaire à
seulement 18 jours de la fin de la
période de transition
passé le 31 décembre si aucun accord
n'est trouvé
les échanges seront régis selon les
règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
ce qui implique des droits de douane et
des quotas
une situation que tout le monde semble
vouloir éviter en pleine crise sanitaire
des discussions qui vont donc se
poursuivre même si boris johnson
confirme aujourd'hui qu'un échec des
négociations reste le scénario le plus
probable
alors comment réagit-on côté et
britanniques
écoutez ces réactions de londoniens
contours négociations en cours ndm 1
taxes et le montant de la taxe à 6 c'est
comme une taxe de 30% sur certains
fromages
les gens pourront ils encore se le
permettre et surtout après co-lead vous
pouvez dire que les riches sont toujours
riches et les pauvres sont encore plus
pauvres alors le commerce
nous ne savons pas comment cela va se
passer donc si la livre baisse cela
affectera l'achat car nous achetons en
euros
donc oui il n'y a un risque que nous
fermions l'accord lui-même ne me sera
d'aucun avantage
j'ai perdu mon droit de voyager j'ai
tout perdu donc il n'y a littéralement
aucun avantage à un accord
peut-être pour l'économie légèrement
meilleur mais dans l'ensemble je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait davantage
peu importe nous sommes dehors est les
discussions entre londres et bruxelles
échappe toujours sur trois points la
régulation de l'économie royaume uni le
cadre juridique du futur accord et
l'accès des pêcheurs européens aux zones
britannique et le risque d'une absence
d'accord a déjà des conséquences très
concrètes de longues files d'attentes
dans la ville de calais les importateurs
britannique augmente en effet leur
commande avant une hypothétique hausse
des prix est par ailleurs sur ordre de
downing street
la royal navy chahains mobilisé quatre
bâtiments de guerre afin de protéger les
eaux territoriales un new deal
l'espoir des pêcheurs britannique qui
souhaite récupérer ce qu'ils considèrent
être leur zoo
reste aux chalutiers européens on aura
l'impression de retourner 40 ans en
arrière alors qu'il n'était pas encore
dans nos zones que nous pouvions aller
pêcher et attraper des poissons
je prendrai même inverse alors que je
n'ai pas bu depuis cinq ou six ans je
suis sobre mais là je vais sortir leurs
hommes s'il n'y a pas d'accord nous ne
voulons pas d'un accord vous savez nous
voulons juste récupérer lozeau pour nous
le bon choix c'est le no deal je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait un seul pêcheur
bigand qui ne veulent pas d'un autre
il est nous sommes à présent mais que
charles henri gallois président de
génération fric site
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france énième report donc de
l'échéance de la fin des négociations
est ce que c'est là le signe que chaque
qu'on joue les prolongations dans une
sorte de stratégie mais restent
finalement ouvert aux discussions pour
trouver un accord alors les négociations
ne vont pas continuer beaucoup parce que
comme vous l'avez dit dans votre
reportage l'échéance et le 31 décembre
de cette année et donc ça arrive très
vite et c'est une échéance qui est légal
puisque le royaume uni au niveau du
parlement a voté pour cette échéance et
il ne peut pas y avoir d'extension au
delà du 31 décembre ce qui se passe en
fait je pense que boris johnson ne veut
pas donner l'impression d'être celui qui
claque la porte
mais on voit très bien que le l'accord
que propose l'union européenne est en
tous points inacceptables en fait les
montres c'est finalement la suite
logique de quatre ans et demi de
négociations où l'union européenne n'a
jamais voulu négocier de bonne foi et a
agi on pourrait le dire et c'est pas une
exagération que de dire ça agite
également comme une secte
puisque l'union européenne ce qu'elle
veut elle ne veut pas obtenir un bon
accord elle veut punir en fait le membre
qui souhaitent reprendre sa liberté
et c'est d'autant plus hallucinant quand
on regarde les chiffres puisque l'union
européenne et c'est pour ça que je parle
de sectes joue contre ses intérêts c'est
l'union européenne qu'il ya un excédent
commercial de 86 milliards d'euros
vis-à-vis du royaume-uni et donc l'union
européenne bénéficiant du commerce avec
le royaume uni c'est elle qui a intérêt
à un accord et malgré ça en fait elle
propose trois conditions
vous en avez parlé un alignement total
les normes pour le royaume uni une
soumission à la juridiction européenne
et donc à la cour de justice de l'union
européenne et une ouverture totale de
ses eaux territoriales
ces trois conditions en fait elle ne les
impose aucun autre pays dans le monde
quand elle conclu des accords de
libre-échange l'union européenne a
conclu
des accords de libre échange à travers
le monde toutes ces dernières années les
plus marquants était évidemment le
canada avec le set en 2016 ou avec le
japon le gft à et ces conditions là
elles ne les ont pas imposer à ces pays
et le royaume uni avait une demande
finalement assez raisonnable qui était
de dire nous on veut un accord comme ce
qu'a obtenu le canada or excédent
commercial l'union européenne avec le
canada c'est seulement 10 milliards
d'euros et l'union européenne en fait
est prête à se tirer une balle dans le
pied à faire la politique de la terre
brûlée pour punir le monde qui
souhaitent reprendre sa liberté ça ça a
des conséquences dramatiques pour la
france et les français on va
certainement y revenir mais pour quelle
raison alors à ce que boris johnson le
jour et il le jeu de la poursuite des
négociations célébrer britanniques ne
voulaient pas d'accord il aurait pu
quitter l'union européenne a bien plus
rapidement non les britanniques eux
voulaient un accord un accord de type
canada mais il est clair que le royaume
uni n'acceptera pas l'accord tel que le
propose l'union européenne qui vise
uniquement à punir le royaume uni donc
boris johnson lui dit ma porte est
encore ouverte
et si vous lui proposez un accord normal
comme vous proposer à tous les autres
pays du monde
on sera prêt à l'accepter en fait je
pense que brian johnson ne se fait
aucune illusion sur la mauvaise foi et
l'aspect secteur de l'union européenne
il ne peut pas apparaître comme celui
qui claquent la porte des négociations
ce dernier round des discussions et donc
à vous entendre évidemment un politique
du côté du royaume uni notamment
oui très clairement parce que boris
johnson il faut se rappeler de cela il a
été élu sur cette question là le slogan
de campagne de boris johnson c'était
galbraith sinden faisons le bre xixe
donc bon et johnson s'est très bien en
fait que toute sa crédibilité politique
dépend du fait que soit il obtient un
accord qui est normal et in qui ne nuira
pas aux britanniques ou soit il sort
sans accord mais il sait très bien qu'il
ne peut pas plier les britanniques quand
ils ont voté en 2016
ils n'ont pas voté pour un brésil avec
accor ou sans accord ils ont voté pour
reprendre le contrôle et reprend le
contrôler c'est certainement pas être
soumis aux normes de l'union européenne
ou être soumis à la juridiction de
l'union européenne et donc dans ces
conditions là tels que l'union
européenne propose cet accord il est
très clair que boris johnson préférera
une sortie sans accord que de se plier à
ces conditions qui encore une fois ne
sont demandés à aucun autre pays au
monde et l'union européenne a une
attitude finalement qui dépassent
l'entendement et c'est très malheureux
pour la france parce que la france a un
excédent de 12 5 milliards avec le
royaume uni
je pense à nos pêcheurs je pense à nos
agriculteurs qui exportent massivement
la masse je pense à nos salariés de
l'aéronautique ou les transports et c
sont eux qui vont pâtir de sa cause une
position de l'union européenne qui digne
d'une secte en fait c'est se tirer une
balle dans le pied pour éviter que les
autres pays en fait prennent exemple sur
le royaume uni ait envie de sortir donc
ça absolument dramatique et l'union
européenne et est complètement fou tivo
là dedans
un new deal est donc un synonyme à 2 de
droits de douane ou de quotas ça risque
évidemment de bousculer un peu plus d
économies qui sont déjà fragilisées par
les coronavirus avec aussi des
répercussions à attendre sur les
consommateurs
alors concrètement pour le royaume uni
le royaume uni pour à commercer malgré
deux sorties sans accord aux règles de
l'om c est donc quand on se fait savoir
que les droits de douane extérieur moyen
de l'union européenne sont très faibles
c'est la zone du monde qui se protège le
moins c'est de l'ordre de 2,4 pour cent
et donc le royaume uni même avait une
sorte une sortie sans accord pourra
exporter très facilement sur le
continent en revanche le royaume-uni qui
est libre qui ne dépend tout ne dépend
pas de 26 autres états pour mener une
politique commerciale ou pour augmenter
les droits de douane une pourront s'ils
le souhaitent augmenter les droits de
douane vis-à-vis de l'union européenne
et le faire très vite et de manière
unilatérale et indépendante et donc
c'est plus justement l'union européenne
qui va en pâtir je pense que le seul
fait en fait qui peut permettre que
l'union européenne fléchisse et aille
vers un accord classique c'est que les
industriels allemands mettre la pression
sur angela merkel pour obtenir un accord
parce que l'excédent commercial de là
ma vie du royaume uni énorme c 32
milliards d'euros et vous allez avoir
tous les constructeurs de voitures et
autres qui vont aller voir angela merkel
parce qu'ils vont avoir peur de perdre
le marché britannique ou du moins d'être
remplacés par des véhicules qui viennent
d'autres pays donc je pense que la seule
perspective d'accord c'est celui ci
c'est l'allemagne qui mettra la pression
sur l'union européenne pour préserver
son excédent commercial extérieur parce
que l'allemagne on le voit au niveau de
l'union européenne essaye de défendre
ses intérêts nationaux alors que
emmanuel macron c'est tout l'inversé
celui qui est le plus dur
quant aux négociations de l'union
européenne alors que la france a intérêt
à un accord dont on l'a déjà vu avec le
budget de l'union européenne ou avec le
plan de relance de l'union européenne
emmanuel macron au nom de au nom de
l'union européenne sacrifiera toujours
la france et les français
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
charles-henri gallois président de
génération frac site l'union européenne
qui s'est réuni à 27 cette semaine un
sommet plusieurs sujets abordés dont
l'environnement et la turquie mais la
priorité c'était bien le plan de relance
de l'économie de 750 milliards d'euros
longtemps menacée par les vétos hongrois
et polonais il a finalement été adopté à
l'unanimité
quant à l'eau claire d'un grain de sel
les visages fermés et pas décidé les
plus grands dirigeants européens étaient
réunis à bruxelles cette semaine à la
croisée des chemins entre le gouffre
d'une crise majeure et le compromis les
vingt-sept ont choisi l'unité
les chefs d'état n'ont en effet pas
tardé à débloquer ce jeudi le plan de
relance post qu'ovide estimé à 750
milliards d'euros votée l'été dernier un
accord dont s'est réjoui le président du
conseil européen charles michel
maintenant nous pouvons lancer la mise
en oeuvre et reconstruire nos économies
notre plan de relance historique va
faire avancer nos transition verte et
numérique une année 2020 a oublié et des
perspectives à construire pour l'avenir
les contours du budget de l'union
européenne pour les sept prochaines
années finalement dessiner la hongrie et
la pologne réticente souhaite éviter
toute condition arbitraire pour le
versement des fonds aujourd'hui nous
nous battons pour l'unité de notre
continent commun à nous devons nous
comporter de manière raisonnable et
trouver un moyen d'adopter des approches
fiable et de faire triompher le bon sens
pour fournir des services de santé en
cas de pandémie aux personnes qui en ont
besoin et pour apporter une aide
financière aux pays qui sont réellement
dans le besoin pour aider leur
population l'environnement également au
coeur des négociations
les 27 se sont notamment mis d'accord
pour réduire les émissions de co2 d'au
moins 55% d'ici 2030
autre sujet sensible au menu des
discussions la turquie les états membres
se sont entendus dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi pour une première phase de
sanction qui pourrait en appeler
d'autres
les mesures décidées sont des sanctions
individuelles et des mesures
supplémentaires pourront être décidées
si la turquie poursuit ses actions
motif de ces sanctions les activités
turques en méditerranée orientale dans
des zones maritime disputée avec la
grèce un navire turquie à semer la
discorde en menant ces derniers mois des
recherches d'hydrocarbures cette
décision européenne suscite la colère du
président turc recep tayyip erdogan
alors que le navire en question à
regagner les côtes turques depuis près
de deux semaines
c'est assez les agendas de sanctions
imposées en raison d'objectifs
politiques et de fondement et
rationnelle sont nuisibles pour toutes
les parties n'apportent aucun avantage
ou profile une nouvelle peu réjouissante
pour une économie turque déjà en berne à
laquelle il faut ajouter les sanctions
américaines
conséquence d'un contentieux entre
washington et ankara à propos d'un
système de missiles russes acquis par la
turquie l'europe qui tentent de contenir
la deuxième vague de kobe 19 en france
le havre et charleville mézières
commence demain un dépistage à massifs
les deux premières villes de l'hexagone
a lancé l'opération pays
désormais le plus endeuillé du continent
européen l'italie 64 mille personnes
tuées depuis le début de la pandémie
italie passe ainsi devant le royaume uni
et le bilan ne semble pas près de
s'améliorer avec près de 20 mille
nouveaux cas positifs 24 heures des
chiffres qui en inquiète les autorités à
lapproche à des fêtes de fin d'année est
considéré comme le bon élève européen
lors de la première vague l'allemagne
peine à endiguer la deuxième conséquence
les mesures sanitaires se renforce à
compter de mercredi
commerces 1 essentiel et écoles
fermeront médias ce que fit face à
l'inquiétante augmentation des cas de
kobe de 19 l'allemagne prend des mesures
drastiques avant noël après un entretien
avec les dirigeants des 16 états
régionaux ce dimanche la chancelière
angela merkel a annoncé un certain
nombre
fermeture mitford nous fermerons les
magasins à partir du mercredi 16
décembre et ne garderons ouvert que se
vendant des produits quotidiens
essentiels nous veillerons également à
ne pas étendre la vente de produits non
alimentaires dans les magasins restant
ouverts et la vente de produits
pyrotechniques sera interdite avant la
veille du nouvel an oh ce que doit être
une femme ruth cinq ans sont pure
technique force de death fermeture
prévue jusqu'au 10 janvier
une période qui comprend donc les fêtes
de fin d'année au grand désarroi des
commerçants qui espérait se rattraper
sur ce mois de décembre et qui reproche
à l'exécutif un mauvais timing
s'il nous ferme maintenant à cette
période alors que nous devons faire
notre plus gros chiffre d'affaires de
l'année
ce à quoi nous avons travaillé toute
l'année cela me met bien sûr en colère
parce que je pense qu'ils auraient pu
fermer les magasins en octobre
j'ai l'impression que la décision des
politiques arrivent bien tard
personnellement je me suis déjà préparé
toute l'année à une deuxième fermeture
et j'ai par exemple a grandi ma boutique
en ligne et ajouter de nouveaux produits
et honnêtement cela ne me surprend pas
je suis plus surprise que la fermeture
n'est pas eu lieu plus tôt par exemple
en octobre novembre
ce semi confinement arrive après une
précédente salve de mesures qui
comprenait la fermeture totale des bars
des restaurants ou encore des centres
culturels et sportifs
comme la plupart de ses voisins
européens l'allemagne tentent de
s'organiser dans l'espoir de repartir du
bon pied
al'approche de la nouvelle année avec
près de 298 1000 morts les etats-unis
sont le pays le plus durement touché il
s'apprête à vacciner dès demain le
vaccin a failli there be one tech va
dans un premier temps être administrés à
3 millions d'américains les
professionnels de santé et les maisons
de retraite devraient être prioritaires
le remède a commencé à être expédiés
depuis le sinn fein isr du michigan vers
des hôpitaux et d'autres sites dans le
pays
le responsable de la campagne de
vaccination se veut optimiste mais
prudent nous ne crions pas victoire
le savons que la route devant ne sera
difficile nous savons que des problèmes
vont se poser mais nous y arriverons
ensemble collectivement avec l'aide de
toute l'amérique pour résoudre tous les
problèmes
en fin de compte nous avons un excellent
plan qui a été bien coordonné bien
synchronisés bien préparé et bien
collaboré avec tout le monde
depuis le gouvernement dans son ensemble
jusqu'aux gouverneurs des états en
passant par l'industrie commerciale les
états unis où une nouvelle manifestation
prend soutient donald trump s'est
déroulée hier des milliers de partisans
du président sortant se sont réunis à
washington pour contester les résultats
d'élections présidentielles et des
affrontements ont éclaté avec des contre
manifestants au moins cinq personnes ont
été blessées quatre au couteau une par
balle on recense une vingtaine
d'interpellations manifestations alors
que demain les grands électeurs
proclameront officiellement la victoire
à la présidentielle du d
crac joe biden j'aime ce pays et je ne
veux pas qu'il lui arrive de mauvaises
choses
je soutiens trump donc il faut que je
fasse quelque chose ce n'est qu'une
imposture joe biden a été un homme
politique pendant 47 ans il a été
vice-président pendant huit ans il n'a
rien fait il est incapable de faire quoi
que ce soit donc on l'a assez vu comme
ça pourquoi était ce important pour moi
de venir ici aujourd'hui je pense très
naturellement que nous avons une
république a sauvé une constitution à
défendre et nous ne pouvons pas laisser
certains états à agir sans foi ni loi
dans un pays construit sur des lois
voilà pourquoi en france emmanuel macron
rencontrera demain les membres de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat le
chef de l'état pourrait annoncer à les
derniers arbitrages avant la
présentation du projet de loi climat
attendue fin janvier
une occasion pour emmanuel macron
d'avoir selon ses dires une discussion
franche et directe
les représentants la convention espèrent
de leur côté se faire entendre pour des
ajustements sérielle bois organisée à
l'initiative de l'elysée
cette assemblée n'était pourtant pas
prévu dans le processus de l'exécutif
une décision qui pourrait présager un
détricotage des propositions faites lors
des deux premières sessions des
propositions qui avaient été acceptées
dans la grande majorité par emmanuel
macron lors de la deuxième réunion fin
juin
pourtant les 150 citoyens engagés dans
le projet déplore le manque d'action de
l'exécutif pour les mettre en place
alors qu'emmanuel macron au frais en
milieu d'année des garanties sa récente
interview accordée au média brut a fait
naître plusieurs interrogations parmi
les délégués de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat
le 4 décembre dernier le chef de l'état
accordé à brut un entretien de plus de
deux heures trente
retransmis en direct sur internet je ne
veux pas dire que parce que les 150
citoyens ont écrit un truc c'est la
bible ou le coran
une phrase qui a fait grincer des dents
d'autant plus qu'il s'était attiré en
septembre dernier les foudres des
membres de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat en les ridiculisant
publiquement sur la question de la 5g
si emmanuel macron avait jusqu'ici
cultivé l'image de défenseurs de
l'environnement
ces dernières prises de position
contre-productive pourrait lui jouer des
tours
lors de cette troisième consultation le
ton pourrait monter entre citoyens
écologistes et exécutif alors qu'il
sentait le navire tanguait l'un des
garants de la ccc syrie lyon a lancé
dans le but de sauver le projet une
pétition qui a récolté quatre cent mille
signatures
il espère que cette dernière session
pourra encourager le président à revoir
ses ambitions à la hausse
et on parle maintenant au venezuela
une semaine après des élections
législatives remportées par le parti de
nicolas sma doro mais boycottée par
l'opposition est marqué par une très
forte abstention
allo président autoproclamé du venezuela
juan jose haedo
elle s'est félicité d'un succès
historique selon lui une consultation
populaire qui demandaient notamment aux
électeurs s'ils estimaient ces
législatives légitime
elle s'est achevée ce dimanche selon les
organisateurs 6 millions 400 mille
personnes il y aurait participé des
chiffres difficilement vérifiable en
raison du caractère officieux de
l'initiative mais des images de sites
prévus pour le vote à moitié vide
en parallèle les supporteurs du
président nicholas maduro se sont
rassemblés une marche dans les rues de
caracas pour afficher leur soutien
ils ont défilé en arborant les couleurs
du parti à du président et cet après
midi sur notre antenne à claudio call
fuir secrétaire national du parti de
gauche et spécialiste de l'amérique
latine dans les bottes lorsque vous avez
des sanctions qui touchent directement
l'économie et les sanctions notamment de
l'union européenne on voit bien que ces
sanctions ont comme objectif de miner et
de détruire ce cette économie et sa
touche avant tout malheureusement le
peuple vénézuélien etc et c'est
justement là tout le problème car hier
enfin il ya le 6 décembre ces 4 million
de personnes 4 millions de vénézuéliens
qui ont voté pour
pour pour poursuivre pour faire un
changement notamment législatives et qui
ont reconnu totalement ces élections
plus si vous avoir vous rajoutez les le
million et ainsi de suite d'autres
personnes de l'opposition
ça reste quand même des chiffres qui ne
faut pas prendre à la légère
effectivement l'abstention a été a été
forte et je pense que personne ne doit
se réjouir d'une infection forte mais je
pense qu'il ya quand même une grande
frange de la population qui votent
encore qui souhaitent justement que
healy et didier des politiques de
répartition des richesses et qui
s'affrontent
je dirais à une diplomatie
internationale qui est de plus en plus
guerrière est la situation dans le
haut-karabagh la russie signale une
violation du cessez le feu une première
depuis la signature de l'accord le 10
novembre dernier une déclaration qui
intervient alors que l'arménie a
rapporté des attaques de l'azerbaïdjan
contre des villages rester sous contrôle
des forces du karabagh bakou ac son côté
dénoncé des provocations arménienne
ajoutons que des contre mesures
adéquates avaient été prises
sachez par ailleurs qu'erevan dément la
mort de ce soldat arménien annoncée par
des médias azéris évoquant une
désinformation le pour jean de gliniasty
directeur de recherche à l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques cette violation du cessez
le feu n'est pas surprenante on écoute
en fait cet accord comme tous les
accords est un accord qui ne qui ne
satisfait pas pleinement les deux
parties on sait très bien que à bas coût
il ya des gens qui pensent que alief a
trop cédé qu'il aurait dû récupérer le
haut karabakh est allé jusqu'au bout de
son combat
et quant à l'arménie on sait très bien
que bas chinian est en difficulté et
qu'il a une opposition qui demande son
départ à cause de cette défaite donc
personne n'est pleinement content et
c'est là qu'intervient évidemment le
comment dirais-je le le médiateur avec
les forces présentes
ils sont des forces russes qui sont là
sans doute pour longtemps et qui doivent
réguler en fait un double mécontentement
sur un fond quand même comme gage de
nécessité d'une paire ressenti en tout
cas par les arméniens
et je pense aussi du côté de en tout cas
d'allier et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour un nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique ça fait quand même beaucoup
tout ça
le fondement de la politique c'est la
rumeur ont réagi